[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i'm going
to explain a comic science fiction
action film called iron sky
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
in 2018 an american spacecraft named
liberty lands on the moon's surface
after landing the ship unveils the
election campaign poster of the current
u.s president it has been sponsored by
the president to promote her re-election
campaign the spacecraft carries two
astronauts named sanders and james
washington sanders's mission is to
inspect the surface of the moon for
chemicals as he does he reports back the
presence of helium-3 on the surface he
then wanders off a bit further from
their ship and loses connection with the
mission control sanders is surprised
when he comes across a gigantic helium-3
mine with several people working on it
astronaut james is near their spaceship
waiting for sanders sanders turns around
to call him to come and check the mine
but a person wearing a nazi armband
sneaks up behind him and shoots him dead
a shocked james tries to run to his ship
but the person blows up the whole ship
leaving him no way to return home he
falls on the ground and is surrounded by
people wearing nazi armbands he is then
taken somewhere through the well-built
roads inside the mining base the camera
zooms out showing us the swastika-shaped
nazi base somewhere else on the moon a
german teacher named renate richter
teaches a bunch of school children as
they study we know that the children
were born on the moon and have never
been to the earth renate teaches the
kids to speak in english claiming that
the language will help when they return
to earth to help humanity as it turns
out when the nazis were defeated at the
end of world war ii some of them escaped
to the dark side of the moon to avoid
being killed the soldiers have since
created a colony and have been living on
the moon's surface for generations in
complete secrecy the nazi soldiers bring
astronaut james to the nazi commander
klaus adler at their base adler presents
james in front of their leader wolfgang
quartzfleisch referred to as fuhrer by
his people meanwhile on earth the u.s
president talks about the campaign's
failure to her campaign manager she had
chosen james for the mission because he
is an african-american so that she can
gather more african-american votes in
the coming election the president
demands her manager to do whatever she
can to cover up the mishap back on the
moon adler fetches renate to come and
speak to james in english adler and
renate seem to be in a relationship
james manages to attack the german
soldiers and frees himself from
captivity but is stuck in the base as he
doesn't know the way out he mistakenly
knocks out adler and comes across a
surprised renate near the airlock before
the woman can say anything james pulls
down a lever thinking it will open the
exit but instead it opens the airlock
both he and renate are pulled by air
pressure they somehow managed to get
inside and close the airlock quickly by
then adler has caught up with james and
is furious he points his gun at the man
and is about to shoot him but stops when
james mentions he knows the u.s
president
adler wants to extract information from
james so he sends him to dr richter's
laboratory adler and dr richter are
intrigued by james's cell phone and ask
him what it is james answers it as a
phone similar to their computers dr
richter laughs in disbelief dr richter
shows james a huge machine claiming that
it is a computer and his cell phone is
too tiny to be one dr richter suggests
they cut james's brain open to inspect
its size but adler wants to get
information out of him back at the
united nations headquarters an american
un representative gives a detailed
explanation of the failed lunar mission
the u.s president's campaign manager is
frustrated because of the campaign
failing and scolds her employees for
presenting her with terrible pr ideas at
the moonbase adler visits renate in her
room to propose to her for marriage
which on the moon is called the legal
union he presents her with a
confirmation certificate that their dna
matches 97 percent and reveals his wish
to produce perfect offspring with her he
wants to be the most powerful in their
base and rule the earth someday
somewhere else on the base we get to see
the lunar nazis project the battleship
goter demeron which has been under
development for 40 years it is the dream
of the fuhrer wolfgang quartz fleisch to
complete the battleship they plan to use
the battleship to go back to earth and
conquer it dr richter finally realizes
that the cellphone brought by james has
a thousand times more computing power
than all of their computers dr richter
connects the phone to the battleship and
demonstrates its power to the fuhrer
everyone is surprised and impressed when
the small cell phone starts the
battleship but soon it stops because the
phone is out of battery adler asks the
fuhrer for permission to visit the earth
and fetch more such cell phones he
believes that someday the earth will
attack them and they will need the power
of cell phones on their side the fuhrer
claims that no one who went to the earth
has ever returned but adler is adamant
that he will
in the following scene we see james
being kept in a room with speakers near
him that blast nazi propaganda at all
times
renate sneaks in and introduces herself
to him she asks him about his skin color
as she has never met a dark-skinned
person before she also reveals that dr
richter is her father he has been
injecting james's face with a drug to
make him look more aryan renate advises
james to pretend to be a nazi or else he
will be eliminated
soon adler then gets ready to leave for
the earth before he departs dr richter
presents a now aryanized james to him
his skin and hair have turned white
because of the drugs and he is now in
the nazi uniform
he with adler renate and a guard leave
for the earth their spaceship lands on
someone's farm in new york the owner of
the farm shoots one of the guards dead
making the other three flee from the
place
adler steals a vehicle from some men and
asks james to take him to the u.s
president james with no way out takes
them to the president's campaign manager
vivian adler abducts the manager and
throws james out of the vehicle since he
is of no use to him any longer adler
then asks vivian the whereabouts of the
president renate realizes that adler's
mission is to attack the earth which
doesn't align with what they had been
told
she tries to retaliate but adler asks
her to recite what she always does to
her students renate starts saying a
monologue about their aim to bring peace
and prosperity to the world vivian is
impressed by renee's oratory skills and
devises a plan to use her to help
energize the president's re-election
she then takes the duo to meet the
president who approves of the plan they
start a campaign of nazi-style
propaganda to get the president
re-elected and are successful in it
adler and renate enjoy themselves on the
earth so much that they forget their
mission
meanwhile james has been protesting
alone on the streets about the nazis on
the moon
several days pass and renate has been
working for the president ever since one
day she meets james and the two go to a
theater to watch a charlie chaplin movie
when she comes out of the theater she
realizes that nazis were actually
horrible people
meanwhile vivian has started to gather
feelings for adler as she finds him
charismatic vivian starts making out
with adler as the two walk into adler's
office as they make out adler tells her
of his plan to invade earth after
eliminating the fuhrer who is on the
moon
when adler looks up he sees the moon
nazi fuhrer and his men in his office he
has come to earth to find out why adler
is taking so long to retrieve the
computers
fuhrer knowing adler's plan takes the
two hostages just then renate barges
into the room and confronts adler about
his mission she denounces nazi
propaganda finally realizing adler was
wrong the whole time the fuhrer has
decided to kill all of them but vivian
manages to get her hands on a gun she
kills the fuhrer and all of his men
adler realizes that renate has grown to
like the earthlings so claiming that she
has betrayed the nazis he is now about
to kill her but james comes to her aid
and the two manage to run away adler
steals vivian's ipad and announces
himself as the new fuhrer he then takes
the former fuhrer's spacecraft to the
earth's orbit leaving vivian behind
adler launches the invasion of earth
using a fleet of space zeppelins and
flying saucers they destroy the statue
of liberty and ultimately the entire
city of new york renate watches the
nazis destroy the us and devises a plan
she wants to go back to the base on the
moon to bring the battleship got her
damaron and fight the nazis the united
nations assembles to discuss the attacks
the american president appoints an
american mars exploration spacecraft the
uss gwb to fight the nazis but they soon
get overpowered and ask for help from
other nations the spaceships of other
countries come to the rescue adler
returns to the moon after ordering the
ships to fight till their last breath he
has brought vivian's tablet to activate
the battleship got her damaron after all
the countries assembled their military
they managed to wipe out the nazi
spaceships then the spaceships make
their way towards the moon's base adler
boards the battleship and gets ready to
fight the space coalition meanwhile
renate and james sneak into the
battleship as well renate heads towards
the bridge looking for adler while james
goes to meet dr richter the human
spacecraft arrives at the moon and
attacks everyone in the nazi base adler
panics as the moon starts to fall and
orders his men to start the helium-3
engines the battleship ventures into the
air adler then orders for the cannons to
be fired but earth is on the other side
of the moon out of the firing line to
make the earth stand in the line of fire
adler bombs part of the moon meanwhile
renate plays the nazi anthem making the
nazi officers perform a salute as she
walks toward the fuhrer james finally
manages to disconnect vivian's tablet
while renate kills adler by
electrocuting him before he can fire at
earth renate and james narrowly escape
as the battleship crashes into the moon
the u.s president congratulates
commander vivian on their victory but
vivian mistakenly discloses the presence
of large tanks of helium-3 on the moon
and all the un representatives from
different countries hear it all of them
want to claim the tanks as their own as
such a large quantity of helium-3 can
supply energy for several years the un
members get into an argument and the
fleet of spaceships that were working
together turn against each other they
begin to launch missiles at each other's
spaceships and chaos ensues again
on the moon's base renate walks into her
old classroom where the survivors of the
base wait for her she tells them that
they can rehabilitate on earth in peace
she then reunites with washington who
has gained his complexion back the two
finally kiss
the movie ends as the camera zooms out
showing us the half-broken moon
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching